Ich bin in Berlin-Neukölln
geboren und groß geworden.
Ist jetzt auch egal wer jetzt
den Kopf schüttelt oder
wer das witzig findet. Ich
kenne alle Familien und
ich habe noch nie einen
Clan gesehen. Wir
versuchen uns dazu irgendwas einzureden: "Ja, es gibt
Clans, wir müssen alle aufpassen".
Alles Bullshit.
-Ralf was sagst Du?
Das ist falsch, aber total falsch.
13 Fragen, hier kommt die erste.
Was glaubt Ihr: befeuern
Polizei und Medien in Sachen
sogenannter
Clan-Kriminalität rassistische
Vorurteile, wenn Ihr sagt eher ja,
da werden ja ganze
Großfamilien stigmatisiert,
dann bitte auf dem grünen Feld
positionieren, wenn Ihr sagt
eher nein, da geht es
weniger um Rassismus als um
eine unterschätzte Gefahr,
dann bitte auf dem gelben
Feld positionieren. Bitteschön.
Jetzt wissen wir ungefähr,
wo Ihr steht, jetzt legen wir
los. Bushido-Prozess und
Abou Chaker, dazu Drogensumpf
und Polizei-Razzien,
außerdem etliche TV-Dokus zum
Thema und natürlich die
Serie 4 Blocks. Die sogenannte
Clan-Kriminalität ist
mindestens mal ein medialer
Dauerbrenner. Dabei wird,
so der Vorwurf,
nicht nur Jagd auf Kriminelle
gemacht, sondern möglicherweise
auf alle, die
zufälligerweise den falschen Nachnamen haben.
Sippenhaft - Ist also unser Bild
der sogenannten arabischen
Clans nur aufgebauscht
oder handelt es sich im
Gegenteil um eine völlig
unterschätzte Gefahr? Was
glaubt Ihr, auf welcher Seite
dieses Feldes hättet ihr
Euch jetzt positioniert,
auf gelb oder grün? Bin
gespannt auf Eure Kommentare.
Für Euch liebe Gäste,
heißt es ab sofort wie immer,
wenn Ihr einem Argument der
Gegenseite zustimmt,
dann könnt Ihr gerne einen
Schritt auf sie zugehen
nach vorne oder wenn Ihr
sagt: "Das ist totaler Bullshit,
was die da gerade erzählen",
dann geht Ihr gerne
einen Schritt zurück.
Das Ziel dieses Formats und
natürlich auch mein Ziel ist
es, möglichst viele von
Euch am Ende hier in
diesem Kompromiss-Feld zu
versammeln. Das hat schon
diverse Male gut geklappt.
Ich bin sehr gespannt,
wie es heute so wird. In
diesem Sinne: 13 Fragen, hier
kommt Frage Nummer 2 und die geht an Ali.
Ali, Du bist ja nicht nur ein
besonders erfolgreicher
Rapper, Du bist ja auch
der Cousin von besagtem
Arafat Abou Chaker. Der
wiederum gilt als Clan-Boss
oder zumindest als
zentrale Figur in der
Berliner Unterwelt. Bist Du
also nicht nur Teil
einer Familie, sondern auch
Teil eines kriminellen Clans?
Ich bin Teil einer
Familie, aber ich bin kein
Teil eines Clans.
Was machst Du? Was sagst Du
zu Leuten, die sagen,
Du gehörst auch dazu?
-Ja, das ist halt, wie Du schon
gesagt hast am Anfang,
es hat irgendwas
von Sippenhaft. Es ist
für mich nicht einfach jedes
Mal damit in Verbindung
gebracht zu werden. Das
bedeutet egal was ich mache,
in meinem Leben, mir wird
wieder dann nach gesagt Du
bist ja Clan-Mitglied oder
hast Du nicht gesehen.
Mittlerweile nehme ich das nicht
mehr für voll,
weil was soll ich denn machen?
Soll ich jetzt ... Ich wurde ja
nicht vorher gefragt in
welcher Familie ich reingeboren
werden möchte. Und das ist so wie mit,
wie soll ich's Dir vergleichen:
Zum Beispiel Du bist mit
jemandem befreundet oder
Du bist mit jemandem cool
und dann irgendwann kommt irgendwann
der Streitpunkt, dann kommt
immer derselbe Spruch:
"Du bist ja eh von so einer
Clan Familie".
Kann ich gar nicht mehr
ernst nehmen.
Ich finde das Thema ist ein bisschen
in den letzten Jahren ein
bisschen zu heiß gekocht
worden.
Alles, jede Kleinigkeit ist schon heutzutage
Clan-Kriminalität
und das finde ich einfach ein bisschen lächerlich.
Doro was sagst Du.
Du bist ja Polizistin und hast
viel auch mit
dem "Milieu" in Anführungszeichen
zu tun? Kannst Du das
nachvollziehen,
würdest Du einen Schritt auf ihn zugehen?
Ich finde es halt schwierig
insofern, als dass wir ja
auch aus kriminalpolizeilicher
Sicht wissen,
dass diese Familienstrukturen
eben sehr verwoben sind,
ja, also man kann das
nicht so ganz trennen.
Ich verstehe aber auch, es
gibt ja auch Teile von
diesen Familien, die sich
eben davon
abgrenzen und sagen: "Nein,
ich habe eben nichts mit
diesen kriminellen
Machenschaften zu tun. Ja,
ich grenze mich davon ab."
Kleinkriminalität ist meiner
Meinung nach gefährlich,
weil es das subjektive
Sicherheitsgefühl der Bevölkerung
deutlich beeinflusst.
-Ich hab' nie behauptet, dass es sowas
gibt, also kriminelle
Machenschaften. Ich bin der
Meinung, die gibt es gar nicht
also in meiner Familie.
Die Suppe wird immer heißer
gekocht als sie gegessen wird.
Aber wenn es jetzt hier
nur um meine Familie
geht, hab' ich auch gar kein Bock
mehr hier mitzumachen.
Sag ich ganz ehrlich.
Ne, es geht ja eben nicht nur um Deine Familie.
-Ich sag ja nur. Wenn es nur darum geht...
-Um Deine spezielle Familie
geht's sowieso gar nicht.
Na dann ist ja super.
Also ich würde einen Schritt auf ihn zugehen,
weil wenn ich mir vorstelle,
dass ich jetzt hier stehen würde
und in dieser Art und
Weise über meine Familie
gesprochen werden würde, dann löst das
natürlich auch eine
Emotionalität aus und ich finde,
das Beispiel von Ali
Bumaye zeigt eigentlich,
wie gefährlich es ist,
wenn wir alles unter
Generalverdacht stellen und wie
schwierig es ist, auch mit dem
Thema Clan-Strukturen, fair
und gerecht umzugehen.
Und trotzdem finde ich es
wichtig, dass wir nicht
erst die Frage stellen des Rassismus,
ob das sozusagen rassistisch ist,
wenn man das benennt. Es
geht ja darum, dass von den
Menschen, von denen
Verbrechen begangen werden,
dass die dafür auch die
Konsequenzen in Kauf nehmen müssen,
unabhängig davon,
ob sie Ali heißen, Achmed heißen
Michael oder Melanie,
das ist sozusagen der Ansatz.
Aber wenn einer dabei ist,
der sozusagen unschuldig
ist und auch unter
Generalverdacht gebracht wird,
dann haben auch wir als
Gesellschaft versagt und genau
das finde ich, ist die
Herausforderung, und ich
finde, das kommt eigentlich
ganz deutlich zum Ausdruck.
Das heißt, Du darfst gerne auf ihn zugehen
in dem Falle und trotzdem
muss man natürlich sagen,
das BKA hat ja sogar
eine Definition, die sagen
Clan, der besteht laut
Polizei aus Angehörigen
ethnisch abgeschotteter
Subkulturen. Also es gibt
ja offenbar, Doro,
dann doch irgendwie eine
Kategorie, auch wenn die
irgendwie sehr schwammig daherkommt.
Ja also das Problem: Meiner Meinung nach hat die Politik
das so ein bisschen
verschlafen, sozusagen früh genug
anzugehen. Deswegen
gibt es diese ethnisch
abgeschotteten Subkulturen.
Also wenn man sich jetzt
mal anguckt, wie war das
vor 3 Generationen zum
Beispiel. Ja, da haben wir...
es sind Flüchtlingsfamilien beispielsweise
hergekommen, die eben aus ihrem
Land geflüchtet sind,
aus diversen Gründen, und kommen
dann in ein Land,
wo sie damals noch nicht
arbeiten durften und so weiter
und so fort. Und wie gehen
die damit um?
-Aber Mohammed glaubst Du denn,
dass wir jetzt aktuell
bei solchen Definitionen,
wie ich sie gerade
vorgelesen habe,
den richtigen Weg gehen?
Also wenn man das überhaupt
Definition nennen kann,
also schwammig ist, glaub ich
auch sehr diplomatisch
ausgedrückt. Ich habe mich
jetzt jahrelang damit
auseinandergesetzt und auch
kritisch auf die Polizeiarbeit
in verschiedenen
Bundesländern geguckt und da ist
sehr viel falsch gelaufen.
-Vielleicht ist aber auch
nochmal wichtig, beim Thema
Clan-Strukturen, das ist ja
kein Kavaliersdelikt.
Clan-Kriminalität ist für mich
deswegen ein Problem,
weil es Opfer generiert. Das
sind keine Bagatelldelikte,
es geht um sexuelle
Ausbeutung, es geht um
Prostitution. Es geht um
organisierte Kriminalität. Und
meistens kommen die Opfer selber aus den Milieus.
Deswegen müssen wir darüber reden.
Die Tatsache,
dass viel schief gelaufen ist,
als die Menschen gekommen sind
vor über 30, 40 Jahren,
dass es die Residenzpflicht
gab, dass man nicht
arbeiten durfte, ich habe viel
mit diesen Jungs, auch in
Neukölln, viel Zeit verbracht
als Redakteurin, hab mit
ihnen gedreht und da war
keiner dabei, der keine
Träume hatte oder der nicht
partizipieren wollte an der
Gesellschaft, aber es war
de facto so, dass sie
nicht arbeiten durften.
Aber nochmal,
ich glaube, die Verantwortung liegt bei den
Menschen immernoch,
die diese Verbrechen begehen
und das sind auch diejenigen,
die diesen Nachnamen in
Mitleidenschaft ziehen. Mir
tun die Familienmitglieder
leid, die damit nichts zu
tun haben, aber kollektiv
mit in Haftnahme genommen werden.
Aber der Generalverdacht,
der kommt ja
nicht von
den Familien, der kommt ja
von der Gesellschaft,
die da drauf schaut. Also
irgendwie scheint ja der
Umgang, zumindest laut Mohammed,
der Falsche zu sein.
Aber man muss doch darüber
berichten können, wenn das passiert.
-Darüber berichten ist ganz wichtig, da können wir
auch nochmal Medienkritik machen.
Einige Kolleginnen und Kollegen
lassen sich einfach Dinge erzählen.
Wir sind die Harten, wir gehen
durch Neukölln, 4 Blocks
gucken und dann nochmal in
die Reportage reinkippen
und das kommt tatsächlich
kriminellen Menschen
zugute, weil die auf dieses harte
Image aufbauen.
Beim Thema sogenannte Clan-Kriminalität,
mit der ich mich auch als
investigativer Journalist
auseinandergesetzt hab',
kann ich sagen: Ich bin kein
Kriminologe, weiß aber,
dass Polizeiarbeit,
die nach rassistischen Mustern
funktioniert, nicht im Sinne
unserer Sicherheit ist und
mehr Schaden anrichtet,
als dass sie Dinge aufklärt.
Wenn wir sagen, in Berlin
gibt es zum Beispiel 1000
Fälle pro Jahr an
sogenannter Clan-Kriminalität,
wenn man sich die
Statistik anschaut und das
haben sehr wenige Kolleginnen
und Kollegen in der
Vergangenheit gemacht, dann
findet man tatsächlich
Drogenkriminalität oder
Zwangsprostitution,
neben zu schnell gefahren auf der
Autobahn
oder zu langsam gefahren auf der Autobahn
und dann kann
man sich irgendwie da auch noch mal
die Dimension des
Problems anschauen. Wenn sich
ein Innenminister
hinstellt, egal in welchem Bundesland und sagt:
"Ich hab' diese Kriminalität" und
ganz viele Kolleginnen und
Kollegen bei der PK nicht
kritisch nachfragen, läuft
da auch aus medialer Sicht
etwas falsch.
Da können wir auch mal bei Dir nachfragen, Ria, du bist ja
Strafverteidigerin und
Du hast viel mit dem Thema zu tun.
Hat man mit dem falschen
Nachnamen Schwierigkeiten,
sagen wir mal vor Gericht?
Also wenn man vor Gericht ist,
dann hat man ein Problem
auf alle Fälle, egal mit
welchem Nachnamen.
Ich meine, dass ein großes Problem
darin besteht, dass die
Medien so tun, als sei
das die Kriminalität an sich,
sowohl in quantitativer als
qualitativer Hinsicht.
Und das stimmt einfach nicht,
das ist ein Bereich von
vielen, der absolut
überbewertet wird.
Was ich berichten kann ist auf alle
Fälle, dass es im Nachgang,
also beim Vollzug von
Gefängnisstrafen und so weiter, auch
Probleme gibt, weil die viel weniger
Chancen bekommen als andere
und da gerne anders behandelt werden
sollen als andere. Und der
normale Mensch, der normale Inhaftierte,
der sich da eben nicht diesen
Vorurteilen ausgesetzt sieht.
-Was heißt anders
behandelt werden wollen?
der sich da eben nicht diesen
Vorurteilen ausgesetzt sieht.
-Was heißt anders
behandelt werden wollen?
Na, zur Frage von, ob den Chancen
gegeben werden,
sich in sogenannten Lockerungen zu
bewähren und all das da wird
dann eben gerne aus
Sicht der Staatsanwaltschaft,
die denjenigen dann
OK-Vermerk aufdrücken,
ohne dass das Gericht das, also
ein OK-Vermerk heißt,
dass gesagt wird, derjenige ist der
organisierten
Kriminalität zugehörig, obwohl das
Strafgericht das gerade
nicht festgestellt hat, die
sind dann einfach mehr
belastet und in ihrem vollzüglichen
Fortkommen gehindert.
Ralf, was antwortest
Du darauf?
Also die Sache mit dem Generalverdacht ist ein Problem.
Für viele aber nicht für alle.
Ich finde es wichtig,
über diese Problematik zu
berichten, weil ich gesehen
habe, wie diese Problematik
immer größer wurde und die
ist sehr eng mit der
Migration verbunden,
und man hat sie jahrzehntelang
einfach übersehen.
Bei manchen Familien, wenn ich ein Geschäft
habe und jemand bei mir arbeiten will,
dann werde ich mir richtig
überlegen, ob ich das tue, weil ich weiß,
wenn bei dem kleinen
Konflikt, da hab ich die ganze
Sippe vor dem Laden
und ich kann nicht mehr raus.
Und das ist der Unterschied
zwischen dieser
Clan-Kriminalität und der
organisierten Kriminalität. Sie
beruht auf Verwandtschaft.
Kannst Du das nachvollziehen, was er sagt?
Hast Du das schon mal erlebt selber?
Ja, weiß ich nicht. Wenn mein
kleiner Bruder ein Problem hat
komme ich natürlich.
Wenn ich, wenn ich dafür Clan bin
dann bin ich Clan,
dann bin ich Clan.
Gut du nennst es aber
Familiensolidarität?
100 Prozent, ist doch mein kleiner Bruder.
Ganz kurz Düzen, ich hab
es nicht vergessen.
Wie bewertet Ihr das,
was er gerade gesagt hat?
Also ich finde diese Haltung
die mag allenfalls
für Psychologen interessant
sein, das ist einfach
Schwachsinn, finde ich
ganz ehrlich.
Wieso?
Es ist einfach Schwachsinn sich darüber aufzuregen,
dass Menschen zueinander
halten, ja und erst recht,
wenn sie familiär
verbunden sind, ja in jedem
anderen Kontext würde man das
erwarten voneinander und
wird das gepredigt und
gelebt, ja oder vermisst,
wenn es hier nicht mehr
so ist. Das wäre bei
deutschen Familien doch
genauso ja und zu sagen wenn
wenn es einen Konflikt
gibt, ein Konflikt ist noch keine Straftat
ja, und daraus kann man
auch nicht herleiten,
dass wenn es ein Problem gibt und
ein großer Bruder sich
für einen kleinen Bruder
einsetzt, dass damit eine
Straftat einhergeht,
und es ist vor allem Schwachsinn
zu behaupten, dass
Clan-Kriminalität, also dass die
Straftaten miteinander
begehen müssen, weil sie
miteinander verwandt sind.
Aber Ihr berichtet ja von
Einschüchterungsversuchen,
das heißt möglicherweise von Nötigung.
Das hast Du ja gemeint.
Ich will nur
wissen, also das
davon berichtet er, dass Dir das...
Bei der Justiz kommt noch schlimmer. Also wir
haben eine Paralleljustiz, die versuchen
die Probleme untereinander zu
lösen. Ich nehme ein Beispiel:
Ich wurde doch bedroht und
stand unter
Personenschutz. Es gibt 2 Wege,
entweder halte ich mich an den
Rechtsstaat und verhalte
mich, wie ich gemacht habe,
mit allen Nachteilen oder:
Ich habe Kontakte in der
Gruppe, Ich kenne viele Leute,
16 Jahre lang habe ich
mit denen gearbeitet
und die alte Generation
war in meinem Büro in
der Beratungsstelle,
der Weg von denen wäre,
dass ich jemanden einschalte,
dann gibt es ein Treffen
mit denen, ich
entschuldige mich, wir küssen uns
und die Sache ist erledigt.
Verstehen Sie. Da stand
ich vor der Wahl.
Ich glaube, wir dürfen das auch nicht
miteinander vermischen
Es ist ganz wichtig, das merkt man
ja auch gerade, ich komme
selber aus einem
Kulturkreis, der kollektivistisch
geprägt ist und das ist ein
ganz großer Unterschied
zu einer individualisierten
Gesellschaft. Ich habe
10 Geschwister, wir sind 11
Kinder zuhause, ich habe
eine große Familie. Das
heißt, wenn wir dieses Thema
ansprechen, beispielsweise auch das
der rassistisch gelesenen
Menschen, die benachteiligt
werden und das ist einfach Fakt,
lass uns die Sachen
benennen, wie sie sind,
wenn du den falschen Nachnamen
hast, kriegst du keine
Wohnung und kriegst auch nicht
den richtigen Job und da
muss noch nicht mal Abou Chaker
heißen mit Nachnamen.
-Kein Bankkonto.
-Das heißt, das ist schon mal klar, dass da eine
Benachteiligung ist bei Menschen
mit sichtbarer
Migrationsgeschichte. Wenn aber noch
der Kriminalitätsaspekt
dazu kommt, dann ist das
natürlich noch mal eine andere
Komponente und dann
finde ich es falsch,
das nur rassistisch zu lesen.
Das heißt, es ist ganz
wichtig, glaube ich auch für
die aufnehmende
Gesellschaft, auch für Deutschland
als Einwanderungsgesellschaft,
im Zeitalter der Pluralisierung
zu verstehen, was da
passiert und zu überlegen,
was wir alle daran sozusagen
ansetzen können und tun
können, damit der Nachname
Abou Chaker in 20 Jahren
nicht mehr mit Kriminalität in
Verbindung gebracht wird.
Was meint Ihr? Besteht ein Generalverdacht,
wenn Du den falschen Nachnamen hast?
Vielleicht habt Ihr ja
sogar den "falschen"
Nachnamen. Was sind Eure
Erfahrungen? Fragen wir doch mal
die Polizistin, wir haben
ja eine da. Gehen
bei bestimmten Familiennamen die
Alarmglocken an auf dem Revier? Sagt man: "Jetzt
müssen wir aber nicht
mit 2 Kollegen
hinfahren, sondern wir nehmen
lieber mal ..."
Wir sind ja alle nicht vorurteilsfrei,
also wir haben ja alle
Vorurteile. Es ist eben
nur wichtig, dass wir uns
eben auch insbesondere als
Polizei immer wieder
ins Gedächtnis rufen und zu
sagen "Ja wir haben
Vorurteile und wir müssen
aber damit umgehen", wir
müssen versuchen,
so weit wie möglich das Ganze
trotzdem objektiv zu sehen.
Ich bin ja auch nur
ein Mensch, ich bin
kein Roboter und ich würde
sagen: Ja, es gehen
Alarmglocken an, weil man eben
bestimmte Erfahrungen
vielleicht schon gemacht hat
und davon bin ich nicht
frei, also auch als
Polizistin nicht.
Wissen Sie, wann
meine Alarmglocken angehen?
Wenn die Tür mit einem Rammbock
eingetreten wird und ich mit
Springerstiefel auf den
Kopf getreten werde, obwohl ich ganz
allein in der Wohnung bin.
Da gehen meine Alarmglocken an.
Wenn man jahrelang nicht mehr schlafen kann,
wenn man irgendwas im Hausflur hört und
wenn man dann hört:
"Wir haben uns in der Tür vertan."
Weißt Du was ick meine, da gehen
meine Alarmglocken an.
Ist Dir das passiert?
Ja, ist mir passiert. Zweimal hintereinander.
So und genau darauf
zielte meine Frage ab. Bei der
so genannten
Clan-Kriminalität gibt's ja die
Politik der 1000 Nadelstiche,
sagt man, und genau da
wird über die
Verhältnismäßigkeit gesprochen.
Also: Muss man mit einer
Hundertschaft einen Späti zum
Beispiel kontrollieren
gehen. Ich übertreibe
jetzt ein bisschen. Was
würdet Ihr denn vorschlagen?
Was wäre denn verhältnismäßig?
Wirklich evidenzbasiert
einfach Kriminalität bekämpfen.
Es kann ja nicht sein,
dass der Bezirksbürgermeister
von Neukölln zusammen mit
der Polizei und einigen
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
sich absprechen, um etwas zu
inszenieren. Ich hab' das
auch noch mal nachrecherchiert:
In der Sonnenallee
großes Tamtam, viel Polizei.
Immer, wenn ich nachfrage
danach "Was wurde
eigentlich gefunden?" entweder ein
paar Kilo unversteuerten
Shisha Tabak - und
ich bin nicht dafür, dass Shisha
Tabak nicht versteuert wird oder so,
und das war es. Und das geht
nicht, aber dann ist das Kind
schon in den Brunnen
gefallen, weil in der
Boulevardpresse, in öffentlich
rechtlichen Medien auch oder
auch in Privatsendern schon
diese Bilder quasi
gesendet worden sind. Und da würde
ich mir wünschen,
dass weniger auf Inszenierung und
mehr auf faktenbasierter
Polizeiarbeit und
Berichterstattung gesetzt wird.
Wenn man denn das erste Lagebild
der Polizei über
Clan-Kriminalität von letzter
Woche sieht, dann
sind die Straftaten, die Masse der
Straftaten, ziemlich
beachtlich. Also das ist kein
Bagatelldelikt und das
ist nicht aus Bösheit
und Antirassismus
also Rassismus, dass die
Polizei sowas macht. Ich kenne
die Arbeit der Polizei.
Ich weiß welche
Anstrengungen sie macht und welche Ergebnisse
sie haben, man braucht nur
ihre Berichte zu sehen,
um zu merken, wie ausgewogen,
wie vorsichtig und
wie sie an der Sache ganz,
ganz sachte rangehen.
Genau um diesen Vorwurf von Rassismus
entgegen zu kommen.
Aber überzeugt Dich das Ria, was er gerade
sagt, weil es gibt ja
offenbar kriminelle Strukturen,
die man angehen will.
Also es überzeugt mich nicht.
Ich will das nicht kleinreden.
Natürlich gibt es
Straftaten in dem Bereich und von diesen
Leuten begangen,
aber was mich ganz erheblich
stört ist, dass da sehr,
sehr unter die Linse
geschaut wird und ein sehr enger
Tunnelblick vorgenommen wird
und sich überhaupt nicht damit
auseinandergesetzt wird, was Kriminalität
ist, wer Kriminalität
begeht. Kriminalität ist immer
auch ein Mangel an
Möglichkeiten und wie sich das
entwickelt, und
man muss da einen viel größeren,
auch einen zeitlich größeren Blick nehmen.
Aber das finde ich jetzt
gefährlich, was Sie sagen,
weil ich finde, dass Sie das
jetzt damit relativieren.
Das ist ja das
Totschlagargument zu sagen, es gab
keinen anderen Ausweg und
deswegen musste jemand in die
Kriminalität abrutschen
also ich glaube, Sie sollten auch
auf die Entscheidungsfähigkeit
des Individuums
setzen und ich finde,
das ist damit relativiert.
Also was Du eben gesagt hast, dass wer auch immer, ein
Remmo, wir können ja auch mal
einen anderen Namen ins
Spiel bringen,
dann die anderen Remmos belastet,
wenn er sich selbst strafbar macht
also ich hab noch kein
Strafricht...
Das habe ich nicht behauptet, da legst Du mir was falsches in den Mund.
Doch, dass die die Verantwortung für ihre
eigenen Straftaten
tragen und damit auch verantwortlich sind, wenn dann
andere Remmos die keine begehen,
diskriminiert werden.
Wenn Sie ein Verbrechen begehen würden, dann
sind Sie doch selber dafür verantwortlich,
oder wollen Sie das ...
Ich bin verantwortlich, aber ich diskreditiere damit nicht jemanden...
Natürlich tun Sie das, automatisch!
Ist denn der Straftäter Müller, ist der denn verantwortlich? Wird dem dann
von irgendeinem Strafrichter auf der Welt als Strafzumessungsgrund
gesagt: Also da gibt's nochmal 6 Monate extra für, dass Du
dafür sorgst, dass ich jetzt mein
Leben lang alle Müllers
doof finde.
Also, das kann man in dem Sinne nicht vergleichen,
weil es dieses Konstrukt bei der Familie Müller nicht
gibt. Ich kenne es nicht,
ich persönlich kenne es nicht, aber
wenn dem so
wäre, dann gilt dasselbe
natürlich auch für Familie
Müller genauso wie
für die italienische Mafia.
Also deswegen, das
ist für mich sozusagen keine Frage ...
-Das ist ein Moralisieren und das
hat mit Rechtsstaatlichkeit ...
-Es ist eine Frage der Verbrechen,
werden oder eben nicht, halte ich mich
an diesen Rechtsstaat oder tue ich das nicht und es ist mir
Es ist eine Frage der Verbrechen
die begangen werden oder eben nicht, halte ich mich
an diesen Rechtsstaat oder tue ich das nicht und es ist mir
mir wirklich egal wo
derjenige herkommt.
Kannst Du damit gehen, dass
natürlich die Schuldigen auch im Fokus stehen?
Der Straftäter ist für das verantwortlich,
was er gemacht hat, strafrechtlich ist
er dafür, zur Verantwortung zu
ziehen oder muss
muss mit den
Konsequenzen leben.
Aber der trägt keine
Verantwortung für wen auch immer,
wie der dann behandelt wird
von der Gesellschaft.
Die Gesellschaft trägt die
Verantwortung dafür,
wie wir andere behandeln.
Genau so habe ich das ja auch gesagt, dass
derjenige für sich selber verantwortlich ist,
aber wenn die
Gesellschaft dann beispielsweise
den Sohn oder den Bruder
anders liest, dann haben wir
ja sozusagen das
Zusatzproblem und dafür müssen
wir natürlich die ganze
Gesellschaft mit sozusagen verpflichten.
-Dafür ist der einzelne Straftäter nicht verantwortlich.
Wir haben diesen Tunnelblick, weil wir
nun mal nur mit diesen
Leuten konfrontiert werden,
die da in Verdacht
geraten. Aber wir sehen all die
anderen Remmos,
Abou Chackers, Al-Zeins, sonst wen nicht
die ein ganz normales Leben
führen, die vielleicht
nur zwei Geschwister, zwei Kinder
haben oder auch
zehn und sich keiner von denen
strafbar macht und von denen
gibt es ganz, ganz viele.
Ja und die müssen wir noch mehr sichtbar machen und
sehen, da bin
ganz bei Dir.
-Das bin ick doch, Mensch.
Ja eben, Du bist ja auch heute hier.
Dazu würde ich eben auch gerne nochmal was sagen.
Nun ist aber so, dass
ja auch
Strukturermittlungen ergeben haben,
dass Gelder zum Beispiel, die
durch die Großfamilie
erwirtschaftet werden, eben auch
als Unterstützung auch in
diese Familienteile
trotzdem mit reinfließen. Ob sie
nun mal was damit zu tun
haben wollen oder nicht,
ob sie selber Straftaten
begehen oder nicht,
-Das ist mit Sicherheit kein
arabisches
Phänomen.
-Geldwäsche. Und Deutschland ist Geldwäsche
Land Nr. 1. Seit Jahrzehnten vielfach
abgemahnt von der
Europäischen Union dafür
und von allen
anderen, ohne dass das irgendwas mit
irgendeinem Araber zu tun hätte.
Aber der Punkt, den Düzen jetzt
mehrfach hervorgeholt hat, nämlich,
dass die
Kriminellen auch mit dafür
verantwortlich sind, dass die
Familienmitglieder in
Mitleidenschaft gezogen
werden. Da könnte man ja auf der
anderen Seite fragen:
Müssten sich nicht die ganzen
rechtschaffenden
Familienmitglieder noch
stärker, vielleicht sogar öffentlich
noch mehr distanzieren,
-Ich hab ein Problem damit dass wir schon so tun,
also wir reden gerade so nach
dem Motto: "Wir haben Clans,
die sind Safe, wir sind sicher
da und jetzt reden wir
über die Opfer der Clans".
Ich bin in Berlin-Neukölln
geboren und
groß geworden. Ist mir jetzt auch egal,
wer jetzt mit dem Kopf schüttelt oder
wer das witzig findet,
Ich kenne alle Familien und ich hab noch
nie einen Clan
gesehen. Dass es Leute
gibt, die Scheiße bauen
kann sein. Das heißt, das sind alles
gute Familien, ich kenne
die alle, ja, die sind...
Es gibt gute Leute, es gibt
schlechte Leute. Ich hab Nachbarn die sind
scheiße, es gibt Nachbarn
die sind gut, ja, aber ich
hab noch nie in meinem Leben
einen Clan... was für ein
Clan. Dass es immer
jemanden mal gibt der Scheiße baut. Kann ja
wirklich passieren,
auch in meiner Familie gibt
es Leute die Scheiße bauen, will
ich nicht verneinen. Aber
hört doch mal auf mit
dieser Clan-Geschichte.
Also Du sagst es gibt gar keine
organisierte Kriminalität?
Nein gibt es nicht, ich hab 150 Cousins vielleicht
in Berlin. Wenn ich jetzt
auf der Straße
laufe und wir werden
angegriffen und wir prügeln uns dann,
ist das dann
Clan-Kriminalität? Kein Vater sagt zu
zu seinem Sohn: "Geh mal jetzt raus und
mach mal so und so", sowas gibt es garnicht.
Egal welche
Familie gerade genannt worden ist,
ich kenne die alle,
viele von denen,
das sind alles gute Menschen und dieser
ganze Humbug. Wir
versuchen uns da irgendwas einzureden
irgendwelche
Stimmen in den Köpfen
zu suchen "Ja, es gibt
Clans, wir müssen alle aufpassen" alles Bullshit.
-Ralf, was sagst Du?
Das ist falsch, aber total falsch. Der Beweis:
ich beziehe mich - und als
ich mein Buch geschrieben
habe - auf die Berichte
der Polizei und die Polizei,
das ist eine Antwort
auf was sie gesagt haben, die geht
ganz vorsichtig damit um. Also die
haben ganz empirisch
angefangen. Die
haben festgestellt,
dass bei jeder Aktion, die treten
immer als Bande auf, jede Aktion,
das sind immer dieselben Leute.
Und dann haben sie
gecheckt und da haben sie
gefunden, das sind ihre
Verwandtschaft, also die sind
nicht von den Namen her
ausgegangen, sondern von
den Taten. Und dann haben
sie festgestellt es gibt
hier eine Art Organisation,
die auf der Verwandtschaft
beruht. So ist der Begriff
Clan-Kriminalität
entstanden.
Mohammed ist ja nun Journalist und der
Neutralität verpflichtet.
Du hast ja dann auch sehr viel
in dem Thema recherchiert.
Mohammed ist ja nun Journalist und der
Neutralität verpflichtet.
Du hast ja dann auch sehr viel
in dem Thema recherchiert.
Was glaubst du, gibt es
kriminelle, organisierte Strukturen?
Ja oder Nein?
Natürlich gibt es kriminelle, organisierte Strukturen,
die heißen Wirecard zum Beispiel. Die heißen aber
auch keine Ahnung... Bestimmte
ethnisierte...
Airbnb...Springer-Verlag...
Diese Diskussion gerade
da ging es um
Dimensionen des Problems und
ich würde gerne an einigen
Beispielen nochmal das
kritisch diskutieren.
Sagen wir mal, dieses kleine
Feld hier ist Niedersachsen und
das hier ist Bremen.
Und Bremen, hat irgendwann mal
gemerkt, diese
rassistische Art und Weise, das zu
framen, das funktioniert nicht,
das war so vor 5, 6, 7
Jahren. Deswegen haben Sie
die Methodik ihrer
Statistik geändert. Das hat
dazu geführt, dass ich in Bremen
total sicher bin.
Da gibt es ein bisschen
Clan-Kriminalität, aber
ist alles ok. Meine
Mutter würde sagen,
„Bremen, kannst du leben, kein
Problem, Statistik alles super".
Wenn ich über die Grenze
gehe nach Niedersachsen:
„Um Gottes Willen, Araber
überall, alles in Flammen" und
das meine ich mit
Statistiken auch kritisch lesen.
Und die muss man wirklich
kritisch lesen, weil was von
staatlicher Seite
aufgetischt wird, das ist meine
Aufgabe als Journalist,
das nochmal zu dekonstruieren.
Dein Plädoyer ist total
angekommen, für mehr
Differenzierung, auch gerade
bei Statistiken,
Polizeistatistiken. Aber
das ist offenbar eine
Schwierigkeit bei diesem
Thema, überhaupt
eine Definition zu finden.
Und trotzdem müssen wir mal fragen,
wenn, wie Ali sagt
"Es gibt keine Clans",
haben wir dann kein Problem?
Aus meiner Sicht haben wir bundesweit ein Problem,
dass jedes Bundesland
für sich so ein bisschen Clan-Kriminalität
definiert und eben sagt "Ja,
das hier ist ein Clan".
Bei Clans verbindet man
sofort ja nicht die
Deutschen, sondern die
Araber. So ist es halt,
das ist gesellschaftlich
einfach so, ist halt ein Begriff,
mit dem man mittlerweile so
ein bisschen was
anfangen kann.
Wobei die meisten der sogenannten Araber
ja Deutsche sind oder viele.
Ich kenne Deutsche, dagegen sind die
Araberclans, Kindergeburtstag,
glauben Sie mir das.
Es geht ja darum unabhängig
davon, wo man herkommt, das gilt natürlich auch für
die andere Seite, also wenn
wir, wie dieser Tage
mit Korruptionsvorwürfen
konfrontiert sind, die haben
nichts mit arabischen
Großclans zu tun und da möchte
ich jetzt auch nicht
relativieren, aber
da werden ja auch
Gesetze gebrochen, da wird ja
auch Vertrauen
missbraucht und ich glaube,
es ist ganz ganz wichtig,
dass auch alles im Blick zu haben,
auch wie du es angesprochen hast
und sich nicht immer
nur auf einen Tunnelblick
zu konzentrieren und
diese "Unconscious bias"
also diese Vorurteile,
die wir alle selber
haben, auch immer wieder zu hinterfragen.
Und natürlich macht es
dann auch Sinn, über solche
Begrifflichkeiten zu diskutieren, denn
nochmal: Wenn jetzt daraus abgeleitet
wird, dass jede arabische
dann auch Sinn, über solche
Begrifflichkeiten zu diskutieren, denn
nochmal: Wenn jetzt daraus abgeleitet
wird, dass jede arabische
Großfamilie kriminell ist,
dann ist das hoch
gefährlich und entspricht auch
nicht der Realität.
Und auf der anderen Seite
glaube ich eben
schon das, ganz klar.
Jetzt ist Ria, glaube ich einen halben Schritt nach vorne gekommen.
Ja, auch tatsächlich, weil ich mich an die
Spielregeln erinnert hab.
Ja, sehr gut, warum bist du nach vorne gegangen?
Ja, weil Du Sachen gesagt hast, die ich okay
finde. Also dass wir natürlich alles in den Blick
nehmen müssen und dass es
nicht sein kann, dass wir
jetzt ableiten: Alle
arabischen Familien seien kriminell.
Viele Schritte seid
ihr noch nicht gelaufen.
Das überrascht mich bei dieser
Art der Diskussion nicht
unbedingt, bei diesem
Thema vor allem, denn es ist
auch wirklich ein
bisschen diffizil, aber
zumindest...Ria, bist Du wieder
nach hinten gelaufen?
Und Du stehst, Düzen,
von Anfang an... Oh schau mal du gehst
ja immer noch weiter vor.
Was müsste passieren, damit Du einen Schritt vorgehst?
Weiß ich nicht, schwer zu sagen jetzt. Also die
Dame in der Mitte hat schon Sachen gesagt, die ich fühle, klar,
aber ich weiß nicht, das ist mir alles
so ein bisschen so...
Weiß ich nicht.
Ich glaub, wenn man
keine so schönen Worte hat,
soll man am besten Mal den
Mund halten.
Du hast uns doch schon mit sehr schönen
Worten beglückt heute.
Ja, aber das war es dann auch.
Vielleicht kann ich auch was zu ihm sagen.
-Ja, Bitte!
Ali ist auf jeden Fall auch ein Vorbild für
viele Kids da draußen.
Gerade auch durch seine
vermittelnde
Art, seine verbindende Art, durch seine
Social Media Auftritte.
Und ich glaube, das es ganz
wichtig ist, sich genau
darauf zu konzentrieren,
also auch
wie wir sozusagen werteorientierte
Präventionsmaßnahmen, Bildungsmaßnahmen, Möglichkeiten, Empowerment
schaffen können
und ich glaube,
wir brauchen auch Role Models
aus ganz unterschiedlichen
Bereichen, die es de facto
nicht gibt, aber ich glaube
wir müssen uns noch
viel mehr auf die
verantwortungsbereite Gesellschaft
von morgen konzentrieren
und das muss auch die
Politik verstehen, dass das im
eigenen Interesse sein muss,
wenn jeder Dritte
Migrationshintergrund hat in
Zukunft. Also die Frage ist
nicht nur was ist ein
arabischer Großclan, sondern was
ist Deutsch? Und dass wir
letztlich auch alle
Teil dieser Gesellschaft sein
müssen, egal
wie wir aussehen und wo wir herkommen.
Wenn wir das wollen, wenn wir
das wollen und die Ärmel
dafür hochkrempeln,
müssen wir aber auch die
Möglichkeiten dafür bekommen.
Frage an Euch ist: Was haltet
Ihr von dem Clan-Begriff?
Wir haben hier
diskutiert, gibt es eine Definition,
die Euch zufriedenstellt,
oder ist das totaler
Schwachsinn, diesen Begriff
überhaupt zu verwenden?
Wenn wir ihn nicht verwenden,
wie können wir das Problem,
so wie es Ralf gesagt
hat, wie können wir das
Problem trotzdem angehen? Denn
es gibt ja offensichtlich
ein Problem mit
organisierter Kriminalität. Also was
sind die Begriffe,
was habt Ihr für Erfahrungen beziehungsweise,
was habt Ihr übrigens bis jetzt
aus dieser Diskussion
gelernt? Schreibt es mir gerne
in die Kommentare. Ich weiß
es ist nicht einfach,
aber wir versuchen natürlich
trotzdem irgendwie aufeinander
zuzukommen. Und das wollen
wir jetzt auch tun. Wir
wollen in so eine Art
Kompromiss-Runde. Ist jetzt ein
bisschen schwierig,
dafür sind wir noch ein bisschen
weit voneinander entfernt.
Aber vielleicht können wir
uns ja auf gewisse Thesen einigen. Ich
fang mal mit einem an,
mit der Frage der Kommunikation.
Ich glaube, da sind wir
uns ziemlich einig
gewesen. Also wenn wir davon
ausgehen, dass die mediale
Berichterstattung über
sogenannte arabische Clans verzerrt
die Realität darstellt in
Sachen organisierter
Kriminalität insgesamt.
Da muss man sagen, man hat den
Eindruck, die sogenannte
Clan-Kriminalität ist
riesengroß. Du hast
mehrfach gesagt, so groß ist das
gar nicht. Manchmal wird
es auch größer gemacht
durch Statistiken. Zudem
werden bisweilen auch
nicht immer rassistische
Klischees befeuert. Da sind
wir uns, glaube ich,
in dieser Runde auch einig
gewesen also ich sag mal,
der Minimalkompromiss wäre
jetzt meine Frage 11:
Wir treten deshalb ein,
wir alle hier für eine erhöhte
Sensibilität in der
Kommunikation sowohl bei Polizei, Medien,
als auch bei uns selbst. Könnt
ihr euch darauf einigen?
Dann würde ich Euch bitten,
einen Schritt vorzugehen,
das ist, das war so,
dass wir mal so abchecken,
wo wir hinkommen so und jetzt
merkt euch bitte,
wo ihr steht und steck mal die
Köpfe zusammen. Ich bin
gespannt, was dabei rauskommt.
Weil das eben stigmatisiert wird?
Da kommst Du gar nicht mit?
Einfach nur rauszuschlagen, was das
Gesetz überhaupt vorsieht.
Merkt Ihr selber.
Aber natürlich habt Ihr jetzt
auch die Gelegenheit. Was
ist der Kompromiss?
Sagen wir mal eine These,
vielleicht ein Appell, eine Bitte,
die Ihr formulieren könnt,
wo sich alle, grün wie
gelb, einigen können? Ich bin
gespannt, ob Euch was eingefallen ist.
Gerade bei diesem schwierigen Thema.
-Keine Ahnung. Es ist schwierig.
Habt ihr irgendwas?
Auch nicht?
Uns fällt nichts ein. Euch? Habt ihr was?
Ich bin gegen Konsens.
-Ist auch voll okay.
-Der gute Streit ...
Ist auch okay. Also ich frage
jetzt Gruppe Gelb: Habt ihr
einen Kompromissvorschlag?
- Also um einen Kompromissvorschlag
zu machen,
muss man eine gemeinsame Basis haben,
auf den Begriff Clan
kann man nicht verzichten.
Geht es bei euch drüben,
gibt es da irgendwas,
wo ihr sagt: "Mensch
damit kriegen wir sie"?
Die Frau Anwältin
spricht bei uns.
Also natürlich kriegt ihr uns
mit Forderungen nach
frühzeitiger Integration,
danach einen Gesamtüberblick zu
behalten und sachlich zu
bleiben. Es ist ... da
gehen wir natürlich mit, klar.
-Also frühe Hilfe statt
späte Härte? Ich überspitze
ein bisschen, um einen
Punkt klarzumachen:
Lieber nicht die
Hundertschaft zu Ali schicken
und das Geld investieren in
einen Sozialarbeiter?
-Einfach mal klopfen ...
-Einfach mal klopfen. Also
ich fasse zusammen.
- Anders: Weniger Racial Profiling und
mehr der Spur des Geldes folgen.
Weniger Racial Profiling und
mehr der Spur des Geldes
folgen, könnt ihr dem folgen?
Jeder geht so widerwillig so
einen kleinen Schritt vor...
Ja, klar gehe ich damit und
ich rede aber auch
darüber, wer welche
kriminellen Taten begeht und wie
sich das entwickelt.
Und wenn heute gesagt
wird, das sind die Araber,
dann, weil da heute eben ein
Blick drauf geworfen
wird und einmal deshalb,
das ist auf alle Fälle
eine politische Entscheidung,
wer verfolgt wird,
wer gerade verfolgt wird,
weil die Ressourcen
nicht da sind, alle zu verfolgen.
Ja, und jetzt ist es gerade
gewollt, das es die
Araber sein sollen.
Und wo ich auch mitgehen würde, oder
was auch meine Forderung
wäre, auch wenn es
vielleicht überrascht, dass man
die Polizei und die
Strafjustiz einfach viel,
viel besser ausstattet.
Auch ein Kompromissvorschlag.
Da kommt ein ...
Eben also nicht nur
mit besserer Technik,
sondern auch intellektuell
um es mal so zu sagen.
- Nicht nur Technik, sondern
auch intellektuell besser
ausstatten.
-Ich weiß diese
Diskussion ist wahnsinnig
anstrengend und sehr
komplex. Ich bilde mir trotzdem
ein, dass man eine gewisse
Empathie für verschiedene
Positionen hier entwickeln konnte.
Wir werden am Ende hier
niemanden im Kompromiss Feld haben.
Ehrlicherweise finde
ich das nicht total
überraschend bei dieser
Diskussion. Ich danke Euch sehr,
dass Ihr trotzdem teilgenommen
habt und euch immerhin
auch ein bisschen bewegt
habt. Vielen Dank.
- War gerade
nicht böse gemeint mit: Sie
verdienen kaum was.
ich meine das eher Pro,
für die Polizei.
Ich find' die sind safe unterbezahlt.
Nicht, dass Du das
jetzt falsch verstanden hast.
Dass Du immer noch da hinten stehst,
obwohl du die ganze Zeit
sagst: Du hast recht,
Du brauchst mehr Geld,
Komm, gib dir noch 'nen halben Schritt.
Ich fühl mich hier wohl.
- Du fühlst dich da wohl.
Alles klar, super.
Herzlichen Dank euch allen!
13 Fragen waren das!
Waren das wirklich 13 Fragen?
Ich glaube, das erste bei dieser
Thematik ist wirklich auch das
Schweigen zu brechen. Ich
glaube, wir dürfen nicht
unterschätzen, wie tabuisiert
das Thema ist. Auch aus
Angst davor, Fehler zu
machen. Es ist auch ein
vermintes Feld. Es gibt viele
Verletzungen, Schmerzen auch
auf beiden Seiten. Und ich
glaube, die Kommunikation
darüber ist ein erster
wichtiger Schritt. Und so habe
ich diese Diskussion heute
auch verstanden.
- Ja,
also ich finde es sehr gut,
dass überhaupt darüber
geredet wird. Ja, ich finde es
auch immer gut, konfrontativ zu reden.
Was ich mitnehme: Ich freue
mich über jeden, der sich
ernsthaft damit beschäftigt.
Das Gefühl hatte ich oder
den Eindruck hatte ich bei
Dir ganz doll. Und der da
auch mit Fakten argumentieren
kann und vor allem auch
damit mit Berichten von
Jugendlichen, Betroffenen und so weiter.
Das nehme ich auf alle
Fälle mit.
- Also ich hab heute
definitiv von ihm gelernt,
dass, beziehungsweise mein Bewusstsein hat
sich einfach nochmal ein
bisschen gestärkt. Dieser
Blick auf diese ganzen
Statistiken, ja. Also Du hast es
vorhin sehr bildlich beschrieben.
Und das ist schon so ja,
da müssen wir uns auch
hinterfragen was ist so in den
Medien und so was wird denn da
publik gemacht? Welche
Schlagzeile kommt dann
wieder in die Zeitung? Ist das
vielleicht wirklich so
oder hinterfragen wir uns
vielleicht ein bisschen und
informieren uns selbst ein
bisschen über das Thema,
bevor wir das so stigmatisieren.
Ich bin in meiner Arbeit als
Regisseur und Journalist
hier auf kritische
Perspektiven auch innerhalb der
Behörden angewiesen. Das
heißt, wenn Du was zu
berichten hast, Quellenschutz
100 Prozent, ich finde
es natürlich immer auch
interessant, auch nochmal
der anderen Seite
zuzuhören, um zu verstehen,
was eigentlich vielleicht
ein Defizit ist und ich
glaube, dass wir noch mehr
über kritisches Lesen von
Informationen reden müssen,
sowohl in den Medien,
aber auch von den Behörden ausgehend.
Ja, das war ja heute keine
klassische Pro-Contra-Diskussion,
aber ich glaube,
es ist doch gelungen,
Empathie zu erzeugen für die
einzelnen Argumente sowohl von
Ali als auch Mohammed, Rea
oder Dorotea und den
anderen. Das sind ja alles
legitime Positionen in dieser
Debatte und wenn Ihr ein
bisschen mehr Verständnis
gewonnen habt, dann würde
ich mich freuen.
Ja, wer hat Euch überzeugt,
bei wem habt ihr vielleicht sogar
eure Meinung komplett
geändert? Schreibt es gerne in
die Kommentare!